you have become quite you become an
expert in the life of Jeffrey Epstein
and the crimes of Jeffrey Epstein and
you've released on your channel
I believe it's over a hundred videos
related to Jeffrey Epstein yeah how did
you get so fascinated by the story of
this man and can you elaborate a little
bit more about this appeal published on
him the people who watch and subscribe
to my channel and post comments and
contact me through email social media
they completely steer what I do
everything has done has been at their
suggestions so I've got a prison
questions playlist on the channel ok and
when it when Epstein got arrested people
just started sending me messages what
will happen to Epstein I did a video
titled will Bill Clinton have Epstein
murdered in prison to avoid Lolita
scandal and that was just based on all
my research had done into the Clinton
crime family wait when did you release
that video weeks after he got arrested
and weeks before he got soon as I did so
when he did get suicide it my channel
kind of became this go to Channel four
Epstein News and people just kept
sending him more questions someone so
sent me the unredacted black book quite
quickly before it was in circulation so
I just got on the phone and just started
calling people up like you know trying
to call people like Mick Jagger all
these people so that they all went crazy
viral some of those videos got like an
almost a million views and stuff whoa
so then I just started it got to the
point where at to just do a daily
Epstein video at one point I was doing
to Epstein videos a day and this is like
enough now for about two bucks I think
I'm gonna do who killed Epstein Part one
and Part two I I noticed one of the
videos that you published I was looking
at I don't know if it was a one of the
most recent ones or if it was one of the
ones in the beginning but you were
talking about how Epstein was friends
with Elon Musk and worked with Tesla
somehow in some capacity yeah when Elon
Musk tweeted that Tesla was going to get
boss out and he knew that it wasn't but
he'd been having some dealings with
Epstein and Epstein was hooked up with a
Saudi prince so there was a pipe dream
hoped that that was gonna happen and
musk absolutely should not have done
that tweaks it goes against all the
security laws right right you can't
as a former stockbroker I had to do all
these different exams and get my
licenses and stuff to learn all that
stuff so says the price shock well then
it went right back down and musk got
this huge fine and he was being advised
by Epstein around that time yep so I
guess let's go back a little bit and
talk about Epstein for people who aren't
necessarily privy on all the details of
the case and and and all not necessarily
that case but all the details of his
history with the sex trafficking and the
organizations he was involved with could
you give me sort of kind of like a
description of our backstory of what
that is yeah Epstein started to go out
with you Lane Maxwell who is the
daughter of Robert Maxwell and it was
Robert Maxwell the bra Epstein into the
mossad fold because Maxwell he built
this multi-billion dollar criminal
enterprise whereby he was you know he
could sit down with George Bush he could
sit down with Gorbachev but he was also
a lot and laundering money for all of
that different mafias around the world
Russian mafia the cartels the Colombians
the Japanese Yakuza
and he was feeding information to all
the different intelligence agencies so
we go to Russia
he had money laundering operations set
up through Bulgarian banks and Russia
was in control that through the KGB so
he sat down with the KGB heads then when
he came to England mi5 mi6 will be
asking him what what's the Russians
saying but his heart and soul was with
Israel that's where his ultimate loyalty
was after himself of course he was you
know this this grandiose bombastic
narcissist
now Robert Maxwell he became a liability
to the intelligence agencies I'm reading
the book called the assassination from
Maxim right now and they detail how the
most I'd take him out and make it look
like an accident he's off his job the
lady ghilane and this is off the canary
islands and he's found dead in the water
basically and he's it comes out that
he's looted you know hundreds of
millions from pension funds and stuff
like that and all these people have lost
their money so Robert Maxwell brings
Epstein into the fold and why aren't you
into that fold we're talking iran-contra
you know people saying we don't know
Iraq scenes money came from the money
from these elites comes from the most
profitable businesses in the world and
they're all interlinked and I learned
that because when I wrote about Barry
seal he was a cocaine transporting pilot
for the CIA and it was drugs come up
from South America on these military
planes in his case they were going
through Mena Arkansas and other drops in
Arkansas George HW Bush Oliver North
were heading this scheme and Bill
Clinton's governor of Arkansas was
provided in the state security so it's
drugs in weapons out that's what Maxwell
was heavily involved and he was a key
broker in the iran-contra deal whereby
Reagan was gonna have him you know
release the hostages and that was boost
his popularity in exchange for illegally
giving Iran arms which were financed by
drug deals say it's bringing the drugs
in Gambino crime family was just one the
crime families you know helping them
distribute it so I believe once Epstein
was introduced into that fold
his money would have come from
laundering proceeds for intelligence
agencies what's happening you know
weapons drugs oil and human trafficking
what we see with Epstein is just the tip
of the iceberg
there are far bigger players than him
and he was sacrificed so that those
players wouldn't be exposed including
the Clintons including Leslie wax now so
wax now owner of the limited and also
the limited the companies are limited a
Victoria's Secret Victoria's Secret the
fashion show the you know the lingerie
right and Epstein and Wexner were tight
and the properties the Epstein had you
know were multi millions they came from
Wexler but there's no evidence that he
actually paid for any of them and the
wax the properties in New York it
already been fitted up with all the spy
cameras before Epstein even moved in
Wexler had it all rigged up like that so
honey traps have been used for decades
by the intelligence agencies if you can
entice people into your web people as
powerful and famous as Prince Andrew and
then you could get them in compromising
situations and Virginia Roberts you know
one of the bravest victims is just not
let this lives completely run in with
every single day I'm in communication we
were on Twitter I'd originally go over
on Twitter and retweet her stuffins
offer her support because she's had
multiple death threats FBI have even
said that they're credible
she said that Prince Andrew not only had
sex with her twice individually but also
on a third occasion on the pedo island
had engaged in an orgy with her and
teenagers that were underage whoo
Epstein had procured from East Europe an
Epstein was joking saying you know the
Carly
barely speak English these are the
easiest girls again and one of the guys
he was getting through was jean-luc
Brunel it were also ran a modeling
agency out of France which launched some
very famous moguls and Epstein bragged
that he slept with over a thousand of
jean-luc burnell's girls because of his
connections to the government he was
fast tracking them into the country he
could get them visas just like that
jean-luc Brunel gave him 12 year old
triplets for his birthday present and he
was boasting to the Epstein was boss
since of Virginia about how good the
oral sex was with these twelve-year-old
girls so you know our complete depraved
entity I started writing about the war
on drugs and it led to the Clintons and
the bush crime family and then on to
Epstein in it's it's a very very dark
place now I've got a weekly true-crime
podcast on my youtube channel and one
the most recent guests was Prince
Andrews former royal protection officer
and he was working for Prince Andrew
wangle a Maxwell was just waltzing into
Buckingham Palace she didn't have to go
through the security protocol didn't
have to put a name in the system
properly and we saw Prince Andrew do
that car crash interview on the BBC and
he's talking so polite about a manner
unbecoming and a straightforward
shooting weekend but according to Paul
page the ex-cop you know if guests of
Andrews were held up Andrew would get on
the phone you know say they didn't have
ID or the gut the cops are trying to do
the proper security procedures yeah
Andrew just just get on the phone like
let that [ __ ] person through now
before I [ __ ] come down there
I'll [ __ ] have you lose your job
don't you know who I am
so that's the kind of character he
really was but he's not the brightest
bulb right not the brightest crayon in
the box no I mean Epstein and Maxwell
are at the sharp level and they've got
that psychopathic deviant
of knowledge Andrew I believe was
seduced into that but he wanted to get
that power leverage over him and he
found it so seductive that even after
Epstein had been convicted the first
time around when he got his sweetheart
deal right against the wishes of the
royal family Andrew went back over so
Epstein's four-day celebration from
prison party where Prince Andrew was the
guest of honor and then Andrew gets on
the BBC and says he was going flying all
that way to just to break up his
relationship with Epstein well that BBC
interview was just one big lied the
whole thing even the FBI have called him
out he said I'm really cooperate with
all of the law enforcement agencies and
now the FBI all these people all these
lawyers prosecutors are saying multiple
times they've contacted the royal
Buckingham Palace the lawyers and
Andrews not being forthcoming at all so
the whole thing was just one big whopper
that interview but what Paul page said
was the Royal cop Andrew did know that
whatever he says even if he incriminate
himself he will never spend a day in
jail because the royal family are so
powerful it's one law for them and
another law for the rest of the world
anyone else would have been SWAT team
raided and sense of prison and stabbed
in the belly by the Aryan brothers would
be Mina Sharma
[Laughter]